how are you Dave I'm great hey rich so
what's going on they're in Cleveland
what is the sense you're getting in this
town Dave there is excitement they
recognize that the chasm won their last
eight home playoff games during the
postseason
obviously they opened up with that
disappointing loss to the Indiana Pacers
but eight and one overall and as close
as things were in Games one and two
there is no need there's no need or no
reason to look at the series as being
over the recent history obviously with
the Boston Celtics looking really good
against the Cavs and games one and two
at TD Garden and then the Cavs winning
by 30 in Game three gives some you know
recent history and back up that opinion
and you know my straw poll of players
training staff members coaches on the
Cavs tells me that they're still belief
with inside that locker room all right
so then before we get to that through
the prism of Game one I want to continue
talking Game three with you sir what's
the wrinkle what's the change or is it
just like rolling the same guys out and
just assuming the home court will get a
better result i loo says he's gonna give
a chance to Rodney hood I don't know if
that is okay well here's this guy that
is capable of scoring 20 for us and he's
six foot nine range a guy who can switch
off the Kevin Durant as much as when
Carson can't hit a shot and it can't get
any worse so let's try this other player
and see what happens give him 10 to 15
minutes and if he gives us 6 to 8 points
off the bench that's that's a bonus
that's all good
that's the only stated thing that's
going on in terms of mentality they want
to play more physical and you hear that
in at just about every playoff series
but that seems to be what they think
will unlock them in terms of taking the
tenor of the game over
I mean Game one was the slowest pace
game that the Warriors played all
postseason and Game two the Warriors
were able to speed it up a little bit
get their imprint on the game more so
the Cavs feel like the physicality will
help them slow it down help them play
possession basketball that's one good
thing they've done over the first two
games they haven't turned the ball over
and when they're doing that LeBron James
is the basketball survives and he can
pick apart the defense
all right and as much as I really do
want to go back to Game one and use your
game one reference to turn the page I'm
not ready to do that just yet Dave
McMenamin we had Byron Scott in studio
yesterday and I presented to him what
Lawrence which translate ONC Billups
said at the end of the game game two
that maybe the Cavs should activate
Kendrick Perkins if they really want to
unleash somebody who's physical and
angry and get physical he's the guy to
do it
Byron Scott said why not because you're
you got your backs against the wall
although the caveat being that he is
such a liability on a pick and roll
defense that that it that Ty Lee may not
do that is there any consideration to do
that Dave
I love Byron and Kendrick has been
active for a handful of these 20 playoff
games they played this year but I don't
think that is in the plan so they
Kendrick he works hard
where is the stage his career but you
watch him pregame he's not the guy that
has mobility to play an NBA game at this
point so that's not even I could I could
sense by your your kind response right
there and also your would you say now
you know Dave is longer than I do is
that a little bit of derision in that
response now he just knows it's not a
real possibility so just stop talking
about is what you're saying Dave all
right now let's turn to Game one
LeBron's statement yesterday that when
told that he is receiving criticism
because in the real-time moment captured
by the NBA entertainment cameras after
the all-time rock pool by JR Smith and
prior to starting the overtime LeBron
James just went down a rabbit hole in
which he could not believe the
misfortune that JR Smith had just
brought on everybody as well as perhaps
his coach because he wanted to find out
how many timeouts there were and he had
confirmed to him that this could have
been stopped with a timeout
that criticism his response was hey you
know I'm in the NBA Finals how much more
can I carry my teammates how did that
sit with everybody Dave
you know certain times that I spoke to
him about this specifically and he said
one there's always the camera on LeBron
more so than anybody else and we've all
had these moments that the world doesn't
see too he's allowed to have that moment
of raw frustration we can pick him up in
that moment if our always on him to pick
us up here 49 points at that point of
the game what more can he do and that's
what you did see you saw Jeff green kind
of you know cradle LeBrons head and
getting this year you saw Kyle Korver
clapping his hands trying to create some
positive energy in that huddle that's
okay LeBron James doesn't have to do
everything including selling the popcorn
at the arena for the Cavs
sometimes these non bronze I love that
term I haven't seen it yet I love that
term you mentioned sometimes the non
bronze can carry that that load actually
I think it's much more healthy for the
Cavs team when they do so so I
understand the look ejection on LeBron
space is remarkable and that's something
gonna be sick with people's head along
with everything else the you know the
missed free throw and JR Smith dribbling
out to the three-point line but it's not
his job to also always set the mental
tone for the cab there's other players
there who are professionals who can
carry that that way is there any heat on
tyloo in Cleveland for not calling the
timeout even though he's in a very
geographically unsound position to get
somebody's attention to do it yeah some
people have brought that up but I mean
you're talking him being close to 50
feet away from the play opposite of the
court less than five seconds to go is
the assumption when your player grabs
the offensive rebound in the paint and
it's a tied game that he's going to go
up with it and then the next assumption
is when he starts to take it out to the
three-point line he's going to shoot a
three because that's me that's just what
JR does at that point yeah maybe you
could have said that point nine seconds
left he should be on the floor just like
LeBron was calling timeout but LeBron
was on the court point nine seconds left
feet away from ed Malloy and this LeBron
can't get the time I'll call there what
hope does tyloo have getting the call 50
feet away couple more minutes with Dave
McMenamin
on the Rich Eisen show part of the Honda
insider segment from ESPN so tell me if
I'm reading too much into this LeBron
sit down with with Rachel Nichols and
she asks him about his relationship with
Dan Gilbert and we saw he basically just
breezed right by him like he was in the
HOV Lane for the for the Eastern
Conference Finals championship ceremony
the trophy presentation ceremony and
LeBrons response dave was we'll see when
it comes down to leaving on July 1 or
his free agency decision and then
hearing him yesterday basically saying
you know we're at the NBA Finals how
much more can I carry you know my
teammates that these two really those
responses give a glimpse into him
thinking you know I'm I'm not really a
fan of the owner and I'm not a fan of
the roster you mentioned Rodney I mean
Rodney hood Clarkson these guys that
were brought in mid-february have not
panned out here in June what do you
think that am i connecting dots here
that are appropriate no actually I don't
think you're reading too into much at
all I just want to give a quick context
on two things there one he also said
that he has a great working relationship
with Dan Gilbert and there was a private
moment not caught on camera in the
locker room after Game seven between Dan
and LeBron and also Dan and rich Paul so
you know as I see it that relationship
has been it is it has a level of
stability right now that said he does
not make those comments to Dan Gilbert
about their - about Dan Gilbert to
Rachel with you know it's just coming
off the top of his head LeBron James
very calculated in his messaging and on
the eve of the NBA files he wanted to be
known that he was not a fan of the Kyrie
Irving trade on the record for the first
time the day of the NBA Finals Dan
Gilbert puts out a series of tweets
including complimenting Kobe Altman the
rookie GM for not only the mid-season
trades that they made but for the Kyrie
Irving trade saying that we wouldn't be
where we are
had we not made that trade so that is
some public wrangling between LeBron
James and Dan Gilbert trying to position
sells on who was right about the Kyrie
Irving trade with the biggest game of
the Cavs season coming up in just hours
and that is where there is something to
point to that as much as they have been
able to work together over the last four
years there is a level of mistrust that
exists all the way back to the decision
in 2010 so then why was Dave Kyrie
Irving traded right I mean if if if the
Code Red
why was the Code Red ordered if LeBron
was asking Kyrie not to be touched to
use the good few good men phrase there
Dave and unless because at the time the
narrative was that LeBron and Kyrie
couldn't be Batman and Robin a more
ramen wanted to be his own Batman
correct
so Kyrie Irving was traded because he
did not want to play for the Cavs
anymore LeBron James isn't not the the
his point of contention wasn't
necessarily that the worst thing for our
franchise would be to trade Kyrie Irving
case plenty confession was to trade
Kyrie Irving to our conference rival and
only get that in return is a bad idea
all right so do you think tonight's the
last night that Cavs fans see LeBron
James suited up with some hope on the
line Dave yeah I think they win tonight
I think like I said earlier when we
first started talking there is a great
degree of belief amongst the people that
I've spoke to in this Cavs organization
and that's half the battle they have a
effective game plan where you know
they've been able to take care of the
basketball and not let the Warriors
completely get away from the mobile
offensively and you know they should
have some shots fall and have some of
their role players play well like the
same way Sean let me say a JaVale McGee
played out of their minds in Game two at
Oracle so I think it's a 2-1 series all
that gets the Cavs is probably under
Iguodala making a serious debut in Game
four and if you don't get that game it's
over at five so you think Iguodala does
not play tonight I don't think he does
okay all right so no Iguodala
and if I'm telling my kids we need to
pull up to watch Kendrick Perkins played
and I say paw Patrol instead basically
is what you're sad okay all right Dave
appreciate the insight as always and
love our chats thanks for calling in
appreciate you back that's Dave
McManaman at MC ten on Twitter so Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience